[Alkış]
sizleri gücünü en çok inandığım şey olan
sevgiyle selamlıyorum Feride halde
gemici Ben Hüma Hastanesi yönetim kurulu
üyesi hastane direktörüyüm aynı zamanda
16 yıldır Kayseri Barosu mensubu bir
avukatım
platformun kıymetli organizatörleri
etkinliğin bu seneki sloganını Kendin Ol
şeklinde belirlemişler açıkçasını Bunu
öğrendiğim andan itibaren çok mutlu
olduğunu söylemeliyim Çünkü ben gerçek
bir kariyerin insanın hayattaki
duruşunda saklı olduğuna inanıyorum
bunu sormak istiyorum
biraz isterim
nerededir
hiç düşündünüz mü Ben henüz idealist bir
Lise öğrencisiyken Üniversite
sınavlarına hazırlanırken dönemin ünlü
habercisi sunucusu Ali Kırca
programında gençlere bunu sordu ve Şöyle
devam etti çabalayın koşuşturun ve her
şeyden önemlisi çok ısrarcı olun Çünkü
şans dolananın ayaklarındadır dedi
bu cümleyi ben o vakit kafamda kocaman
bir yere oturtturdum ve meraklanmayı
merakımın peşinden gitmeyi İşte o gün
Ali Kırca'nın o öğretisine borçlu
olduğumu söylemeliyim
5 yılında Marmara Üniversitesi hukuk
Fakültesinden mezun oldum mezun olduktan
sonra Kariyerim ile ilgili ne yapacağım
konusunda biraz kafa karışıklığı
yaşıyordum Üstelik özel hayatımda bazı
sıkıntılar vardı bir fırsat buldum ve
hukuk İngilizcesi eğitimi almak için
cambrid'e gittim İngiltere'ye gittim
burada kaldığım süre boyunca evimi biri
İspanyol diğeri Finlandiyalı iki ev
arkadaşıyla paylaştım Tabii ben oraya
gittiğimde yaşadığım özel hayatımdaki
bazı sıkıntıların dünyanın en büyük
derdinin olduğunu düşünüyordum o
vakitler ama batılı insanların batılı
arkadaşlarımın benzer sıkıntılara sahip
olduklarını ve o sıkıntıları nasıl
göğüslerinde yumuşatıp hayatlarının
akışına dahil ettiklerinde görmek beni
çok etkiledi şaşırdım büyük bir değişim
yaşadım
Türkiye'ye döndüğümde dönüş uçağında
kendimi kozasından çıkmaya hazırlanan
bir kelebek gibi hissediyordum Umudun
başlangıcındaydım 2005 yılında 2006
yılında Babam doktor Erşat batmaz
tarafından hastanemiz henüz faaliyete
girmişti ve ben kararımı vermiştim
onunla birlikte yol alacaktım
hukuk losyonu bir sağlık İşletmesine
nasıl yansıtacağıma ilişkin eğitimler
alarak kafa yorarak çalışarak geçirirken
hayatıma birden bir aşk girdi bu
fotoğraf sanatıydı 20 yüzyılın
Kanımca en önemli fotoğraf
sanatçılarından Fransız Harry
Magnum fotoğraf ajansının kurucusudur
fotoğraf çekmekle ilgili şöyle söylerler
fotoğraf çekmek kişinin aklının
yüreğinin ve gözünün aynı hizaya
gelmesidir der Benim için de öyle oldu
boynunda Fotoğraf makinem
Kapında valizlerim bütün dünyayı
fotoğraf aşkını arşın dedim o dönem
ulusal fotoğraf amatörleri Derneği
kurulmuştu Ve ben de bu arada bir
üyesiydim çok aktif bir şekilde
çalışıyorduk
Türkiye'nin en önemli fotoğraf
sanatçılarından Üstad sabit kalfagil
Tekin ertu Mehmet Teoman
Erdal Kınacı gibi çok kıymetli isimleri
Kayseri'de ağırlama şansımız oldu
onların fotoğraf perspektiflerinden
kadrajlarından hayata bakmayı öğrendim
beni en gururlandıran hadiselerden biri
Nurlar içinde uyusun sabit kalsa giriyor
Hoca biraz her şeyi hemen beğenmeyen
öyle herkesin sofrasını falan oturmayan
bir adamdı hastanede benim çok Uzunca
bir aynı İtalyan sofralarına benzeyen
bir yemek masam vardı ve orada sıklıkla
fotoğraf ve sanat sohbetleri yapardık
beni onurlandıran en büyük hadiselerden
bir tanesi Üstad sabit kalfagilin o
sofraya oturmasıdır
Kayseri'deki fotoğraf dostlarımdan Ayşe
Öztürk bana bir gün
doğum hastaneniz var sende fotoğraf
çekiyorsun
neden bu işi birleştirmiyorsun dedi ben
böyle biraz sırtına sıvazlanıp gazı
verip o an İşin başında kendini bulan
bir Aslan burcuyum açıkçası hemen doğum
fotoğrafları çekmeye başladım 2008
yılında Kayseri'nin ilk doğum
fotoğrafları çeken fotoğrafçısı oldum
bine yakın 1000'e yakın ailenin o
mucizevi yanlarına tanıklık ettim Evet o
zamana kadar bir hastanedeydim ama
annesiyle ve bebeğinin mucizevi o
buluşma anlarını o mis kokulu anları
tanıklık etmek benim annelikle ilgili
ilk hissiyatlarımı getirdi bir gün bir
doğum çekimindeyim
annemizi ameliyat masasına aldık ben
notlarımı kontrol etmek için annemizin
yaşını sordum ekip arkadaşlarıma bu
arada anne uykuya daldı yani anestezi ve
uyuduğunu zannediyorum yaşını sordum 40
yaşında olduğunu söylediler bir iki
saniye sonra masadan bir ses hayır 40
değil 39 yaşındayım dedi annem biz
sonrasında Tabi annemizde bu durumu
paylaşmak durumunda kaldım Çünkü yanlış
anlamasını istemedim Şimdi herhalde
Ağustos ayında 40 yaşına basacak bir
kadın olarak kim sorsa bana bu Hadise
aklıma geliyor ve 39 yaşındayım demek
istiyorum
[Alkış]
Bu arada 2 tane kişisel sergim var biri
41 kere doğum fotoğrafları diğeri de
sevgili dostum yoldaşım Ümran'ın oğluyla
gerçekleştirdim Medcezir belgesel
fotoğraf serisidir
Ben Fotoğrafla iş yaşantısı ile böyle
uğraşırken o dönem Tabii kurumsal olarak
Reklam ve pazarlama faaliyetleri
yapıyoruz biz Posta gazetesi ile
çalışıyoruz Posta gazetesinin
ekibi Kayseri'ye benimle görüşmeye geldi
sevgili Dilek Erkol çok iyi bir editör
iyi bir gazetecidir bana dedi ki pardon
gazeteye Yazı yazsana bir köşe yazısı
yazsana dedi ben hemen Tabi kabul ettim
çünkü hayatım benim edebiyat sanat ve
kültür üzerine
yaşayamıyorum bunlarsız Ama artık biraz
daha çok gezmem gözlemlemem gerekiyordu
ilk fotoğraf gezimi Sinop'a
gerçekleştirdim yazın hayatıma ilişkin
Sinop neden önemli Sinop insanı
doğasıyla çok kıymetli bir şehir ama
bunun da ötesinde 2000'li yıllarından
sonra
müze olarak kullanılan bir cezaevine
sahip Sinop Ceza ve cumhuriyet
sonrasında siyasi mahkumların tırnak
içerisinde konaklatıldığı bir yer
hepinizin bileceği
Sabahattin Ali'nin burada
cezasını çekmişliği vardır ve Sabahattin
Ali'nin
sözlerini yazdığı Kerem Güney tarafından
bestelenen Edip Akbayram tarafından
duymaya alıştığımız
dışarıda deri dalgalar Gelip duvarları
yalar beni bu sesler oyalar
Aldırma gönül aldırma aldırma gönül
aldırma gönül aldırma
dediği gerçekten de dalgaların gelip de
duvarlarına vurdu o Koğuşu görmek beni
çok etkiledi Ama etkileyen Sadece bu
değildi çocuk mahkumlar için ayrılan bir
tarafı vardı Sinop cezaevinin
çok yüksek pencereleri vardı ve o yaş
grubunun Hatta bir erişkinin bile o gün
ışığını içeriye alması dışarıyı
gözlemlemesi çok zordu çok etkilendim
kader mahkumları üzerine bir yazı yazdım
Ey Özgürlük adında
bir hafta sonra beni gazeteden aradılar
dediler ki Hande Hanım bir okur
mektubunuz var Ben heyecanlı Aştım
Sivas kapalı infaz kurumundan bir kader
mahkumu onu bu kader mahkumlarının sesi
olduğum için anladığım için o satırlara
onları onlara yer verdiğim için teşekkür
ediyordu Bu yüzden yazmak çok umutlu bir
direniştir yine çok sevdiğim yazarlardan
o derece şöyle söylüyor anı yazmak
ölümün elinden bir şey kurtarmaktır
Son okuduğum kitapta
Son okuduğum kitapta iki aşık kadın olan
erkeğe şöyle söylüyor diyor ki
dünyada Derdi tasası olan tek insan sen
değilsin acılarını birer hazineymiş gibi
içinde saklama
Etraftaki insanların tonla acısı var
aranızda hiç acı yaşamayanınız Elem
keder görmeyeniniz var mı zannetmiyorum
Çünkü hayatın olağan akışına aykırığı
Peki bu sıkıntılı bu dertli anlarda
içinizden geçenleri bir iki kelime ile
ifade etseniz bu ne olurdu hiç
düşündünüz mü Ben şöyle söylemiştim bu
da geçer
bundan 11 yıl önce 28 yaşındayken 4 evre
foliküler lenfoma tanısı aldım
çok iyi bir yaşamım vardı hiçbir kötü
alışkanlığım yoktu ama işte olmuştu
Tabii bu süreci Ben şifalanma olarak
görüyorum ve şunu da söylemem lazım
doktorların Ali Ünal Burhan Ferhanoğlu
babam Mehmet gemici Erşat batmaz'ın
Medikal yaklaşım ve tedavileriyle
ailemin eşimin Dostlarımı kocaman
sevgileriyle ben bu süreci geçirdim
çok şükür gayet iyiyim
[Alkış]
ama iki kelimeyi Cebime koydum Biri
sabır diğeri Umut Çünkü şunu biliyorum
ki en iyi çıkış yolu içinden geçmektir
meryemanınız Anneler Günü ve haftası
içerisindeyiz Ben kadınların yalnızca
annelikle kutlanması gerektiğini
inanmıyorum her kadın anne olmak zorunda
da değil ama anneli isteyen her kadının
bunu tatmasının bunu hak ettiğini
düşünüyorum Ben de bu arzuyu isteyen bir
anneyi bir kadınım Tabii benim bu
şifalanma dediğim tabir ettiğim sürecim
Daha sonra bazı mekanizmalar bende
Anladığım kadarıyla çok çalışmıyordu ve
anne olamıyordum
doktorların Babam dedi ki handeciğim sen
bir profesyonelsin içindesin bu işin
yani geçirdiğin çok da büyük bir
rahatsızlık var Lütfen bunu dert
etmeyeceksin anne olamayabilirsin Tabii
ben hayatı boyunca imkansızlara
olmazlara inanmayan biri olarak Yeni Bir
Umut sabır ve azim hikayemin başladığını
düşünüyordum o dönem tüp bebek merkezi
kurduk hastaneye Şimdi yeni bir görevim
oraya başvuran hastaların oraya başvuran
çiftlerin hayallerin hayatlarına
katmaktı onları umutla evlerine
çocuklarıyla göndermekti
ekibimiz sağlıkçılarımız doktorlarımızla
bunu başardık çok iyi bir kurum haline
geldik Tabi ben çok yorulmuştum eşimle
biraz uzaklara şöyle tropik bir adaya
gitmeye karar verdik
otele yerleştik ben verandaya çıktım
çıktığımda 2 metre ötemde bir leylek
gördüm
Hayatımda ilk defa bir leyleği bu kadar
yakından
ve hayvan olduğunu
Söyle şimdi o leylek Bir hafta boyunca
uçtu geliriz gezdi Ama tekrar oraya
tüneledi ben evrenin hissetmeyi görmeyi
Bilenler İçin hep bir mesajı olduğuna
inanıyorum çünkü ben böyle yaşıyorum bu
mesajlarla yaşıyorum açıkçası
oradaki mesaj neydi Hüma kuşu Türk
mitolojisinde Umay olarak yerini alır ve
Umay
leyleğin mitolojik hikayelerde akrabası
ve tezahürüdür leylek ne mi yapar leylek
baharı müjdeler iyiliği müjdeler ve Evet
bebeği müjdeler Yani öylesine değildir
Seni leylekler getirdi Ben o mesajı
aldım döndüğümde hemen tedavimi
planladım doktorlarımla birlikte
8 Ağustos 2015 tarihinde embriyo
transferim gerçekleşti bundan iki hafta
sonra kalbimde bir
içimde bir ses bir kalp pıt pıt atmaya
başladı
Bundan tam 9 ay sonra benim için ailem
için güneş doğudan değil ilk kez
kuzeyden doğdu Kuzeydoğu oldum geldi
sonrasında sonra sonrasında adını
Orta Asya steplerinden
esinlendiğim Teoman oğlum aramıza geldi
Darısı hiçbir vakit imkansıza olmazlara
inanmayanların başına diyorum ve ne
diyor ulan der Mustafa Kemal Atatürk
benim için umutsuz durumlar yoktur
Umutsuz insanlar vardır Ben hiçbir zaman
umudumu yitirmedim beni dinlediğiniz
için teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]